you have to accept the fact that the  government totally wants to provide  surveillance on every part of your life  they want to know when you're eating  they want to know if you're eating a  cheeseburger which is very bad because  bill gates wants you to eat his fake  meat that grows in a peach tree dish a  peachtree dish you'll probably get a  little zap inside your body and that's  saying no no don't eat a real  cheeseburger you need to eat the fake  the fake burger the fake meat from bill  gates  okay  so it's just a gaff right i mean who  cares well it's actually much bigger  than just any individual gaff  these people can barely put together a  coherent thought and it doesn't matter  we have a political party we have a  members of a political party in this  country  that don't care about the fact that  their candidates can't think they can't  think  and they still vote for them in normal  countries these folks would not stand a  chance at being in positions of power